foreign
but
tons
foreign
[Music]
we live
12 people already what's goody fam what
could take this head off let's get into
it
officially everyone
what's goody Welcome to our weekly live
stream holy cannoli
we got a lot to get into today fam this
is our weekly q a that we do here
and post your questions
oh we got Jess me in the building John
Mondragon Jerry Kroll the Stars aligned
we rolling deep in here
so I did post um
some questions
or I posted a post in our Facebook group
to where you can post questions you'd
like answered ahead of time
and if you would like to post some in
the live stream we will see what we'll
have time to get to but we have a lot to
get to today but we appreciate all y'all
for hanging out with us
yeah yeah every Tuesday dude
yeah every Tuesday
you're welcome
everyone
I got my hair wet for this
come on turn your mic up you're a little
low
how about now
yeah
better
yeah okay
much better
it's Akuma
says Ola mateys Thai Erskine in the
building asking a question very nice all
right
all right so one second everyone
let's just jump right into it Yoshi
there's a lot of exciting questions to
get to on today's podcast
so if those of you listening to the
podcast
this is actually part of a weekly live
stream we do every Tuesday at 5 PM
eastern time we live stream into our
Facebook group and on our YouTube
channel so if you are not subscribed to
the YouTube channel do that if you are
not in our Facebook group do that
and if you'd like alerts of when this
does happen join our email list which is
linked in the description of this
episode
and let's get into it my friend welcome
everyone officially
what's goody hot breath the verse so
we're going to get to your questions
today
but Yoshi and I
had a comedy experience we'd like to
share with you all From The Trenches you
know we're working full-time comedians
we like to share not only answering your
questions but also Sharon you know we
interview a lot of dope people on here
but we're pretty dope too
and we'd like to give y'all firsthand
point of view on what it is like as a
full-time comedian so Yoshi and I
actually performed at a country club
this weekend
say it again say it to the people in the
back in here
at a country club
yeah this this brings up an interesting
point here of people thinking of all the
different places they can perform comedy
and a lot of people and there's
something we talked about on here before
of thinking it's all comedy clubs or
nothing or you have to appease a certain
Booker to get on stage or something like
this but this event
actually came Word of Mouth from another
country club that we did so we did a
great job at a country club yeah back to
back back to back we did a good job this
country club referred us to another one
and basically how the country club kind
of how I got into the country clubs was
really
asking
reaching out to some country club seeing
who's interested posting on social media
if I know anyone what a weird concept
you just asked yeah wow wow wow wow yeah
instead of uh making an excuse I made a
way oh mate hey you got it bars right
there yo
bazaars that's bars instead of making an
excuse I made a way I do not hate that
[Laughter]
so yeah that's um I just wanted to kind
of share that with the hot breadth of
verses thinking of outside of the box
we're all about self-made comedians that
self-made comedy hustle so what are
different places you can perform Beyond
just the comedy club and a country club
is a great way to do that and get paid
to do it
yeah is is here's the thing about sort
of thinking outside the box is that one
of the things when I moved out to the
suburbs so I live in the suburbs of
outside of Atlanta
I realize that a lot of people within
the suburbs just don't like to travel
into the city to go see comedy that was
just like off you know when I told
people I did comment you're like where
do you go where do you uh perform and as
soon as I said like stuff inside the
city they're like ah we really don't go
down into the city like that which then
dinged in my mind how could I bring
comedy to the suburbs so I built up like
a collection of different places to do
comedy and guess what they come out uh
so that's just one thing to think about
is
not everyone wants to travel that far to
go see comedy you'll be really surprised
how much people love comedy they'll just
go right down the street if they know
that there is a show and that's what I
found out you know over the last couple
years is that people are willing to go 5
10 15 miles to go see comedy
but do they want to travel like 35 have
to get a babysitter all that other stuff
nah not really so that's just something
that I'll say for anyone who lives like
outside like a main city is that there's
also plenty of places to do comedy right
down the street from exactly where you
are so uh I think it's just good to
think outside the box
at Country Club first of all I thought
the first one was nice no no disrespect
to the first one but man the view of
that second Country Club was out of this
world
yeah they had us on the patio
overlooking the 18th green it was it was
nice it was nice it was like yo yeah
when we first stepped there I was like
okay
uh we probably don't shouldn't be here
uh I didn't think we deserved it but I
was happy to be there first sure oh I
think we totally deserved it and I think
they got a great show yeah for sure oh
they got the goods yeah they got the
goodies
yeah yeah for sure
so yeah we just want to share that
experience with y'all that you know
think outside of comedy clubs it's funny
in the comments goat-like personality
said I'm a goat farmer in Norway
I need to find local bars
yeah
yeah wherever you can
give it a go
you know no one's gonna do it for you so
that's just a fun little lesson there
yeah it's uh it was a good gig it was a
fun gig
would you clock me time wise was it 45
or 40.
uh I gave you the light at 30.
oh okay so I'm not sure how long he went
you were the headliner yeah yeah for
sure she was the headliner I was the
host liner I went ahead and
I went ahead and did my time up front
you know I like to you know I'm a
headliner but on gigs like this I like
to get up there and set the tone and
do my time up front but I probably did a
solid 30. to kick it off a solid 38 for
sure hey you know what
I booked the gig
they found me
I I'm the host you know I was just
setting the tone in the tempo
rocked it dude that was great
for sure
yeah I was like oh Joe's going Joe is
going you were just in the pocket that
was just fun you were just in the pocket
at a at a certain point you turned
around and turned around and you were
looking at the green I was like is Joe
looking for a wall right now
but I think we were truly just enjoying
the view yeah it was beautiful dude
gorgeous yeah yeah yeah yeah beautiful
it was fun all around man
indeed yeah and that's not to say anyone
listening
if you're a newer comedian and you host
a show do 10 minutes
you know two seven to ten don't let my
bad
um example sway you oh no no no your
experienced at this right like that
there's nothing wrong with what you did
you were you were in the pocket and
honestly I don't I didn't think there
was really a time limit but they got
three comedians uh you did 30 somebody
else did 25 I did 40. like it was just
but it was a great show all around like
and they got the business like you could
just tell after the show tons of people
came up and were like oh my God we are
so excited that there's comedy here at
this country club yeah it was just it
was just Good Vibes they enjoyed it uh I
think literally I think we literally
shook hands with every single person
because every single person was just
super excited for that comedy so it was
great yep yeah and that's another lesson
from uh producing your own shows my
friends one the other comic was Ali Edge
who was a hilarious Atlanta comic so the
lineup was
diverse not only in just people and who
we are and what we look like but also
our material and our Styles they got a
nice taste of three different styles of
comedians that are all funny so I think
a lot of times
comedians will just book friends
regardless of how good they are now
fortunately you know I have funny
friends and Ali and Yoshi are very funny
but just keep that in mind when you're
booking a show that you're getting paid
to do that like
you want to book people that you know
will do a good job and be professional
and we all hung out afterwards talked to
them we're very nice greeted them got a
few leads for maybe some potential
corporate events so that's another thing
of we've talked about when we had uh Ava
on
who is up in Canada running one of the
biggest shows up there they got her show
Kickback actually got picked up by JFL
this year but she talked about making an
experience greeting people when they get
there thanking people when they leave
all of these little extra details Beyond
just you standing on stage and being
funny are going to be the difference
between you having a one show there or
are you getting referred to do at other
places and they want to have you back
yeah yeah absolutely yeah yeah it was
great and I think just I mean we've I've
always said this
the afterhank is always the thing that
leads to more stuff
after after the gig I mean I I'd say
this and it's been a while since like
I went up last and I didn't have a good
set but like if you have a good set that
means everybody is in a good mood that's
the best time to like talk to people
like if you just had to get set you're
like oh my God or or if you're hosting
and some your headliner crushes it
hang out like people are there and they
want their experience I mean and there
were people taking pictures all kinds of
stuff with us and so it was just it was
just awesome people shared
um it's important people share their
socials with us they're like oh my God
I'm gonna follow you they're like follow
me blah blah blah all this stuff but all
that stuff is just good energy to bring
back into a show and make sure that when
you are producing a show make sure it's
an experience so yeah that's a great
point
and I love just how you slid that in
that you haven't had a bad set in a
while you were just like you know I
haven't been bad in a while but you just
jinxed yourself I don't know when I
don't know how but no I've had I've had
a bad set just not a bad headline you
said oh okay okay yeah okay yeah yeah I
mean no one's immune to struggling on
stage but I just thought you slid that
in there yeah no no I get I get in a
good bad set like a good like once every
month once every two months you know
what I'm saying it's just like it's just
it's a nice little gut check of yo
hey this this ain't what you they're
saying what you want you know what I'm
saying like comedy just like the history
like oh you you think you could just
slide through nah player so yeah yeah I
gotta respect the craft comedy will
humble you at every turn
but that's why we have the hot press
verse and that's why we do these q and
A's every week to help support answer
your questions give each other feedback
I I want to shout out the hopper at the
verse before we get into these questions
that in our Facebook group
there's a comedian Jasmine Young who
posted advice on her first time getting
on stage and it has over 50 comments
nice
I love that I love seeing comedians
helping Comedians and there's another
comedian in here
who just like posted a fill posted a a
joke idea he's like any ideas for tags
and stuff and people giving feedback and
such so that's what I
that's what this whole Community is
about is Comics helping Comics so
I love seeing that
absolutely no that's awesome
but yeah let's get into um because we
got quite a few questions that were
posted ahead of time I think people are
starting to catch on that ooh if they
they post them ahead of time their
questions are more likely to get
answered so
in our Facebook group
the first question
I'm seeing here and are you ready for
this you ready to do this Yoshi you
ready for this let's do it let's go baby
ready I'm ready I'll be honest this was
like
a good comedy weekend
you know what I mean where you had like
good I had like good back to back back
to back shows and just felt great about
comedy it was like reinvigorating all at
the same I think you know also helped to
get paid to do comedy as well so isn't
that nice it's just nice
look at that honey look at that you
go get yourself a cheeseburger baby you
know what I'm saying this one's all me
on me you know what I mean put gas in
the tank you know what I'm saying I love
it nice
yes so yeah it was a good comedy weekend
absolutely and a good lesson and um
yeah thinking outside the box getting
creative with where you try to produce
shows and tapping into your network like
you know who do you know that maybe is
that a country member of a country club
or who do you know who
knows someone who does karaoke that
maybe would like to try comedy night or
something like just you know get
creative there's no one way in this game
there's your way so really get creative
and think outside the box
and uh let us know let us know if you're
watching this later comment on the
YouTube live stream with the kind of
creative ways that you have done shows
or maybe ideas you have for shows that
people could comment and give feedback
on because that's what it's all about
here just Comics helping Comics So
speaking of which
the first question
in our Facebook group is from Mr Logan
Peters who asked
how do you write through a slump I have
been relatively lazy with my writing
over the past week and can't seem to
find the topics to write about or the
time to do it
just in a slump but I'm never gonna quit
exclamation mark
well the easy answer
is the right 10 Club
that we do every morning at 10 A.M in
the Facebook group hot breather Bobby
Sutton posts a new word every single
morning at 10 A.M to spark some
inspiration it kind of just gets the
juices flowing I think like I said last
week it's like Wordle for comedians just
a nice little puzzle to start the day
and I will say
beyond that usually when I'm going
through a slump
it's usually because I'm like I'm trying
to force something
and like I was trying to force an idea
I'm trying to force something to be
funny and I just have to
[Music]
for lack of a better term like not try
to write jokes like literally like
Journal
just make lists or just
honestly a lot of my writing right now
is journaling I'm not sitting down like
oh I need to punch up this joke or that
joke
I'm just writing for the sake of
exercising the muscle and just kind of
going through that practice and that
routine just to keep me sharp on that
end
but most of the time I'm writing
is not okay I'm sitting down and
creating something funny it's literally
just I'm just showing up because I tell
other people to do it so I have to do it
type deal
and it's not fun and most of the time it
sucks but those are the kind of like
slow days that lead to the breakthroughs
so even though you're in a slump just
don't stop fam just lower the bar just
write the date at the top of a page and
be like oh I wrote today and just kind
of lower the this the pressure on
yourself to create something and that
usually helps me to just kind of get
through those slumps
oh my God that's great yeah I mean on
the SATs you get like 200 points just
for writing your name like that's the
lesson just just for writing your name
down just and I think that's what's
great about the
the right Tim Club of just daily writing
I think one thing to also remember is
that sometimes you're always looking for
Perfection when we're writing and really
the Artistry of getting good at jokes is
just practicing the exercise of just
doing it without stopping so sometimes
it's okay that you're like in a slump or
you're feeling like oh I'm not feeling
inspired blah blah blah but just write
that too just write that down I think
one of my favorite exercises of is from
this book called the artist's way and
it's just about it's called morning
pages and it's just simply just writing
out the all the things that are in your
head and just writing it down on paper
and it's just a good exercise it's like
the first thing that you do in the
morning and you just write just
whatever's in your head you just write
it it doesn't have to be coherent it
doesn't have to be good it could be a
shopping list or just whatever is in
your head you just write it down and as
you're thinking of it you just keep
writing keep right keep right and you do
it you usually try to do like three
pages but
whatever you can even if it's like half
a paragraph
just getting through the exercise of
writing is so good for your comedy brain
um and it'll help you get out of the
slump because at least you don't quit
writing
come on
hope that helps our Logan
next up
we can do um fire fire fire fire fire
fire
we're on a roll here fam
uh Greg Brown how can you work on timing
delivery at home it seems like being on
stage is the only way to improve that
skill
at home I think uh so
overall I think just practicing whatever
you're gonna say at home is just a good
exercise but also practicing pauses when
you expect that you're gonna get a laugh
and it's just like just practicing the
pause of just like all right one two and
then you continue based on you know at
the point that you think you're gonna
get a laugh and then if you don't get a
laugh when you actually do perform it
then maybe that part wasn't funny and
then you re-edit that joke so I think
it's just important to actually practice
the pauses at the house
um and then like slow down too I think
that's the big thing is when you get on
stage we tend to rush ourselves as soon
as we get on stage but if you're
practicing sort of the art of slowing
down
um I think it's super helpful one of the
when I did my special that I never put
out like two years ago uh I remember
what a friend of mine who recorded kedar
who recorded his special I think his
special was on Showtime he recorded a
special and he said one of the things
that he did uh that I did as well is
that he would run and just run through
his set so he'd be doing something else
while going through this set and just
saying the set as part of like his
running it is just part of the exercise
but it's just saying the words through
your body in whatever sort of scenario
and Ronnie was just a good way just to
like practice if I'm tired I can still
say these words these words are still
gonna like get out so that's just
another exercise that even if you're
doing something else practice your set
while you're doing something else
yeah I would do it while driving with
like the radio on so I would try to
rehearse with distractions so if when I
performed there was a distraction I'm
more prepared
um yeah in that situation
yeah but that yeah that is a good note I
mean basically yeah rehearsing at home
is just rehearses if you are performing
with the pauses where you expect
laughter to be and things like that like
yo she said
and then when it translates to the stage
you'll start to find where you're going
too fast or where you need to slow down
or where there isn't a laugh and you
need to figure out how to get a laugh in
there or to get rid of everything
altogether so
you just practice at home as if you were
on stage but the stage is where you will
really know though like you can you can
rehearse all day and all night but until
you get on stage that's when you're
really Gonna Know
yeah
um oh Amir said Louis CK said he walked
while
running through his set oh cool he said
that on the flagrant podcast very nice
oh and Becky said there's an app
called pocket sitcom which has can
laughter as a sound effect that helps
that helps Becky pause uh between jokes
and time my set nice
that's really good uh yeah what's his
name said he does that too Mark Norman
on
on hot breath he says he just mentioned
he walks around
his practice his set just by walking
around
um just like in a circle
another good tip on the timing point is
a lot of comics if they have a five
minute set they will rehearse for their
set to end at five minutes
but it's way more helpful if you
rehearse for the set to end at like four
and a half minutes
so when you get on stage you don't feel
rushed you have plenty of time to get to
all of your jokes so if something does
happen or something does go sideways
you don't feel like you need to cram
everything in because you timed it out
perfectly at five minutes
time it out to end at four and a half
minutes and that's going to give you
more time to slow down and be more
confident on stage
oh and speaking of um
past top breath guess I got to do a show
with Paul verzi this weekend and he was
that's a nice little soft Flex as well
just a nice Flex right there
he could not have been more
complimentary of hot breath and what's
going on here so
um I was just thinking of just Comics
helping comics and he was so
complimentary of what we're doing he's
been keeping up with us and following us
and he's like this is what comedy needs
man more like positivity and Comics
helping each other so
yeah I just want to say that while it
was top of mind and we could just kind
of you know squeeze that in there
yeah
um I also got I also hung out with Ryan
long this weekend who was at the Atlanta
punch line
and he's absolutely hilarious he was
hilarious yeah he was like right that
was like
I mean that was like a clinic
especially
watching him navigate a Heckler yes and
still making it super positive and never
Downing the Heckler but made it about
the show and he was getting laughs like
even more like that was something I
would say I haven't seen a lot of like
almost like it was like clinical how he
made sure the Heckler didn't become a
part of the show
and then making it like even bigger part
just not even the heck he didn't even
Heckle the dude he just asked him
questions and then roasted him and then
roasted himself for roasting it was like
just this like good energy of watches
it's almost like watching a master at
work and you could just tell that he's
done this so many times but I love how
he turned the negative Heckler into a
positive thing for his set that was
amazing to watch and he didn't let the
Heckler derail like he didn't give too
much time to the Heckler he was because
this was late show Saturday people were
hammered dude and he would just kind of
hit him and move on and hit him and move
on and he he really kept the show going
at no point did a Heckler become the
focal point they just kind of became
another jumping off point it was amazing
how he danced around all those Hitlers
man and that dude was out of his mind
junk I mean
done I was like oh my God yeah yeah I
mean I think just just watching that
right and you know Ryan has like amassed
like a billion views from all the videos
he's been doing comedy for some time now
he does it in New York started in Canada
like just a solid comic but great hang
hung out with him afterwards but he was
you could just tell he's like a
masterful like executioner at this
comedy game I mean obviously he does the
comedy seller but man crowd work and
heckling skills was like off the charts
yeah I want to I want to get better I
mean yeah I need I need to practice that
that muscle I haven't really dipped my
toes in that I'm about to do a run of
shows that I think I'm gonna start
playing around with that muscle more I
think when I whenever you Steve Byrne I
was like asking about like
what how do you keep it going or like
keeping it it's like keep I don't Beyond
just working on new material like to
like how do you get out of that routine
of just all right I'm writing and
Performing and writing performing and
he's like well this can apply to anyone
at any level but he's like well what
What specifically do you want to get
better at like do you want to get better
at having the mic in the stand do you
want to get better at act outs you know
do you want to get better at you know
crowd work and that was the one I was
like oh I could you know I don't really
practice crowd work that much and he's
like well he's like make that part of
what you want to get better at he's like
you've proven doing comedy so long you
can write jokes you can perform them you
can do a headlining set he's like
stretch yourself and start to practice
that skill set so that's I want to use
this saying it out loud as
accountability to start kind of
exercising that muscle that I haven't
really tapped into much but when I do I
enjoy it but I just I always I'm like I
gotta do my set you know I gotta I'm
gonna get it unrigid you were doing
crowd work at the Country Club you did
you did a good amount of crowd work but
it's like when I would do it I was
always
I was always like leaning back I was
always trying to get back into this set
I wasn't like as Ian bagg talked about
on the podcast about like have an actual
conversation with these people like
really be interested in what they're
saying like I was always I would do a
little bit but then kind of be like all
right well let me get back I'm here for
the set let me get you know I just I
need to I've been in that routine for so
long just so you do your set you do your
set you do your set so I wanna I wanna
break that reflex I also think I don't
think you're conscious of it I think you
are actually a natural crowd worker like
you do it very very naturally and you
don't realize you do it later on
like but you were playing with the crowd
a lot during your set even though you
lean back into your material you were
doing a lot of like back and forth with
them throughout your 38 minutes it was
really great like
my host lining set
because you know what I earned it
you did I've earned the right to
hostline and you know what I'm not
bombing
you weren't bombing for sure no I'm just
trying to know like younger Comics I
don't want them to start trying to do 30
minutes to open a show this is just me
busting your balls it was just it was
just great but you know it's working uh
but it was just good to like you you you
found people in the audience like when
you would say something people will
react a little differently to stuff and
you would respond back with things and
obviously I know you were doing your set
but I think the crowd work is actually
why I think you went longer
differently to different stuff and then
you'd hit them with something else
because it wasn't like you know I I know
you're material well enough but you
weren't like on a script of just like
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam like you were sort
of going back and forth with them and
then going to material based on the back
and forth so I think you actually do it
much more naturally than you give
yourself credit for I think you're just
not conscious that you're doing it so it
just feels kind of natural
kind of like Bobby said Bobby said you
mastered the Heckler at hickstone up in
uh up in uh where was that yeah that was
in Villa Rica oh yeah I did she said you
did over 20 minutes of strong crowd work
and I was like oh yeah I guess I did at
that show now because they were so drunk
that I was just playing
yeah I guess I guess when you see
someone like Ryan do it there's always
The Grass Is Always Greener I guess I
guess it's so I guess I'm always like
well I want to get to that level yeah
yeah I mean what Ryan did was very very
masterful but it looked like you could
just tell that that was just some like
it was in some ancient like Voodoo like
stuff yeah the dude was just getting
worse and Ryan did not falter like he he
didn't make him look bad he didn't like
he didn't make him the center of
attention he just kind of like turned it
and made it about the show and not about
the Heckler and so yeah I think I think
you'll be surprised if you watch some of
your recordings you are doing a lot of
crowd work
well well I appreciate you saying that I
guess more confidence going into this
week where I want to be more like you
said maybe I do it I'm not as aware I'd
like to be more aware yeah yeah yeah so
I'll do that this gotta run this week
I'll be in Mooresville North Carolina
tomorrow and then Lynchburg Virginia and
then Richmond Virginia for anyone
yeah yeah those areas
we going up shouty
um
all right here we go Anthony
partridge
um any tips on storytelling and writing
stories should open mikers tell stories
should you just get on stage and tell it
first and see where it goes I feel like
there's a better way than writing a
10-page story and cutting it down to
three
takes me weeks to edit it down
um
okay yeah that's basically the gist I
think it's storytelling
tips I mean honest
if if you want to get on stage and tell
it and see how it goes go for it I mean
if you're new to Comedy
I've seen so many Comics be like yo I
have this story
I I can't even get it in five minutes yo
I can't believe they're holding me to
five minutes fam I I this this is a 20
minute story that's killer all the way
through like I would recommend
telling the your favorite part of the
story your favorite moment of the story
what you think is the funniest piece of
the story if you think it's a five
minute story I would say what is the
funniest minute and then try other like
and then try other jokes instead of
thinking you're gonna go up first time
and do a five minute story yeah I I
would suggest to any comedian who wants
to do like solid storytelling like set
is that the first time you do it
just know that the second time you
should do it in half the time just to
exercise
getting to the meat of the actual story
the problem with stories is when you
tell a friend a story
your friend is filling in all the gaps
of the commentary that you're not saying
when it comes to saying it on stage
you still have to be funny and there
still has to be jokes in there Chris
Titus has this method where he just
writes the entire story
just clearly just clear out
uh Jeff uh
what's his oh my God
Jeff
Foxworthy also does this he mentioned it
on the podcast where he just writes his
story out he writes the story out and
then goes back through
and then highlights all the funny points
and then escalates the funny areas of
where can I make this even funnier than
where it is I that's just this that that
is what I would try to do
is at least this is a good exercise in
writing at least put it on paper first
and then go through it and then try to
find the funny parts and then try to
extenuate funny parts within the story
uh I think is a good exercise if you're
storytelling I I'm a Storyteller
comedian I would say I'm not a one-liner
I most of my material
are stories
but I get to the punches very very
quickly and hit you with more tags more
punches within my set you're not gonna
find uh you know five I mean I have I
have this ho the HOH joke that's
actually about
a six minute story that I've cut down to
like I've got a two minute version of it
a five minute version of it and then
like a longer extended version of it and
even in a longer extended version of it
I just add more punch lines into it
regardless so in case I need to spread
the story out and it still works so just
know that even with a storytelling set
just know and be ready to have a shorter
version of that story in case you need
to do a shorter version of that story
uh much longer and then a really long
version of that story as well
yeah and mookie said start the story
with something funny and build off that
first funny so yeah that is something
with storytelling is you want to get to
that laugh as quick as possible just
like in your comedy set in general like
you want to open up with a laugh as
quick as possible ideally within 15
seconds of your set you want to be
getting your first laugh
um and again the same with your story
you want to really get to the point
especially as a younger comic I mean you
can see these amazing storytellers
who've been doing comedy for 30 years
and see how they can draw it out to
build up to a point but starting out you
just want to get to the humor and
something Chris Titus because I I've
heard him talk about storytelling as
well and he said that like every detail
of a story is the setup
for a punch line so if you're at a
certain location can you make a joke
about the location if you're wearing
something or if the person you're
talking about is wearing something like
the more detailed the more you can paint
the picture the more opportunities for
punch lines you have in there
um
but
since he asked you know if he should
just go up and try it I mean go for it
if that's what you want to do you know
go for it and see see what sticks and
you may tell a five minute story that
gets one laugh but you know what hey now
you know there's a laugh in there that
you can start to build off of but that's
how you develop comedy you ride off
stage the best you can and then you take
it on stage to really refine it and
learn what's worth keeping and what's
not
yep
Cool Breeze
they're nice we dropping bars
we dropping bars fam
and I uh I got a few I got a few DMS
this week about hosting so
um and you and I both
have years of experience hosting shows
and I think that the questions have
really come down to
uh like how to engage an audience like
when you're doing a set on a show you're
kind of going up there you're doing your
opener and your jokes and you're doing
your set it seems Comics are struggling
with that like all right what do you do
as a host that's different from when you
do your set how do you actually
create a connection with the audience
how do you create an experience as the
host because it's a completely different
muscle from just going up and doing your
set so what what are some ways you like
to to get the crowd going as a host
uh you know I think as a host you are
like you know in comedy not that you're
not allowed or allowed but like it's not
great to ask questions
in your comedic sets mainly because you
never know what kind of answer you're
gonna get but I think as a host it's
actually a really good thing to ask
questions to bring everybody in based on
sort of you're introducing the show to
them so if you're a host and you're the
first person that they see you welcome
them it's a welcome welcome to the punch
line or something like that this is you
know Atlanta's Premiere comedy club uh
super excited that you guys are here uh
just wondering how did you guys hear
about the show like just just that
question alone you'll get like different
spattering of different people saying oh
we saw it online or you know we like the
comic blah blah blah I think that's a
good question I always ask the question
how many people here are married uh
who's got kids and then the kids thing
leads me into like a kid joke right so I
think asking questions that you know can
lead into parts of your bit is actually
a really good way also talk about like
the city talk about something that is
common to absolutely everybody I think
is a good host skill to actually have if
something happened that weekend like a
sports game or I said a sports game
uh if people are celebrating anything is
another common question that's a great
question right if you see like a bride's
Mage uh Entourage or something like that
address that right that way everyone in
the crowd is like with you uh on that
because they all saw it as well right
like the host should pay attention to
those kinds of things within a room
um and so I think also it's just about
making people feel good about what's
about happen like there's just a good or
an energy Setter when you are a host
like and I think it is so important I
don't care what anybody says you gotta
be high energy as a host
to allow everybody else that's coming
after you not to come to low energy you
want as I think the higher the energy
the better as a host just up top because
your headliner and your you know who's
ever after you if it's like a showcase
they don't want to come up to low energy
they're like ah okay all right guys you
guys ready for another comedian all
right
come into the stage
show buyers you can say like who wants
to come up to that you know what I'm
saying like
Joe Byers thank you everyone thank you
yeah but really what I enjoy about
hosting is that your job isn't really to
kill like your job is literally to set
oh and Yoshi's wearing a hot breath
shirt
that's what's up
you're wearing a hot press shirt
so
um if you're watching the live stream
which if you're listening to the podcast
you gotta go subscribe to the YouTube
channel and join in on our weekly fun
here and get your questions answered
live so yeah what's great about hosting
is your job is literally to set a fun
tone like you said like you don't
necessarily have to go up there and like
try to murder you just want to set a fun
expectation for the event welcome people
let them know what they're in for
introduce yourself say like why we're
here you know like even at the Country
Club
uh event we did something I like to do
is as a host is be like the best part
about you guys being so close to Atlanta
Atlanta has one of the best comedy
scenes in the country so you are going
to get to see some legitimate future
comedy stars tonight and I actually set
that expectation of like oh
they're they're here for something
special this like they're here for an
experience that they'll never forget and
the more you can set that expectation as
a host the better your Comics are gonna
do the better the energy is gonna be and
you just keep it fun and light and
that's really gonna help just kind of
set the show in motion
yeah
and I I think I'd also got asked
like how do you recover if a comic
doesn't do well like if you're going in
between Comics you know how do you kind
of address that possible awkwardness
um I always say like
I'm
I don't believe that you have to do a
joke unless the room needs it so I would
say try to bring try to do a joke in
between that if if a comic just left and
you know they pooped the bed to say
try a joke to try to bring the energy
back up or to try to bring laughter back
into the room before you bring up the
next comic I think that's a super
important thing I also think it's very
important that if a comic just destroyed
just did really really well
you do not try to do a joke in between
you keep that energy likes oh my God
that was great give it up for your last
comedian coming up next this very very
funny comedian bam and you go on you try
you do not try to kill the momentum
between good energy from an ending set
to the next comedian you try to keep
that energy going and you just let that
move through I that is my own sort of
philosophy about hosting don't try to
just do a joke just for the sake of
trying to get your time in
yeah and coming from someone like me who
has seen DJs playing sirens and gunshots
yeah if someone doesn't do well you want
to still yeah
[Laughter]
it's always best to keep it light and
positive and understand like we're all
like experiencing this together and be
like hey thank you for being an awesome
audience you know performing is how us
comedians get better so thank you for
being such a like a great audience to
really help us you know develop and in a
like a fun and supportive way I I I
personally like to keep it just positive
and light and not roast the comedian who
just didn't do well and things like that
I just yeah I try to keep it fun and
uplifting throughout
for sure
um I think what's also good if if you've
got like just like a one-liner tag to
something that they last said I would
try that but if you're not getting
laughs for it then stop it
like if your first one hit and your
second one hit then yes do a third but
if your first one didn't hit and your
second one didn't hit
rule of thirds stop doing it
you know what I'm saying and I think but
I think that's a good thing but like
you've got to be one of those improv I
would say improv skilled comedians to
know all right they just said a joke
what's the one kind of tag that I can
add to this thing that would be great
like you did it with my joke on at the
Country Club you literally said
something based on the last thing that I
said oh yeah yeah yeah
and it was great because they're like oh
thank you for that it wasn't like you
needed the energy but it was just a
great way to like bring more energy into
it based off the last thing that I said
and that is also crowd work I think I
think that's like
the awkwardness of what just took place
back into the crowd because they
actually did have like somewhat of a
subtle laugh at the joke a little bit
yeah yeah the awkwardness onto the stage
with you and said we didn't have to do
that did we and then you just made the
joke and it worked and it was great
yeah it was just funny and I think
that's super like a good like eye and a
good ear for knowing when to say
something
because you're paying attention to what
the audience is feeling and that's what
a good host does pay attention to how
the audience is feeling yo a good host
pays attention to the show as well I've
seen so like a host will go out and like
smoke a cigarette or like just you know
just a good like yeah I that's a really
good point a good host pays attention to
the show understands the vibe of the
show at all times host hosting is a job
like
treated as such but I always recommend
comedians host their own show or host a
show
a lot because that's how you start to
learn how to create a connection with
the audience that's how you learn how to
read a room that's how you learn how to
be more interactive and be more
comfortable and conversational on stage
hosting helps you with all those things
a lot of people don't want to do it
because it's hard at first and it's
difficult and requires a lot more than
just showing up with your notes and
doing a set but it's gonna make you so
much better so much faster
yeah yep paying attention is a huge one
dude yeah so you understand the the the
ebb and flow of the whole entire show
Absolutely and it's not that you can't
take a break but like if a comic is
going up for five minutes don't take a
five minute break like you gotta hear
some of his stuff just in case there's
something that he could say I just think
it's up to your point it's just
important to like pay attention to the
Ebbs and flow of the show itself
um and I think you know I always you
never want to not address any kind of
awkwardness
like I forget who said this but like if
you're doing a set and like a glass
breaks and you don't address it you are
not a real comedian you need to address
the glass breaking
like you're not paying attention if all
of a sudden if everybody hears it and
you don't address it
and you're just you just let it go
you're not a real comedian not I don't
want to make it sound bad but like you
gotta address any kind of energy or any
kind of collective thing that takes
place in a room
and it takes time and confidence on
stage to be able to start to react to
these things because for a while
you're literally just on a script like
I'm just saying these things regardless
of anything that happens like you're not
thinking about anything but the next
word so it'll it takes time and Stage
repetition to become more aware and you
can start to instead of just like having
a monologue you'll start to have a
dialogue with the audience but it takes
time
yeah cool so let's run through
um let's do a little lightning round
here uh in the last few minutes here
let's get to as many of these as
possible do we need to set a timer
yeah let's do it based on you and I
we'll probably need to set a timer
um we probably should be hostline on the
podcast yeah for sure for sure
and if new comic I don't know if you
guys know what host lining is but host
lining is when a host literally does
like a headlining set out of the gate uh
and me and Joel have this report where I
make fun of him about host lining
because back in the day he used to host
this room called Java Monkey yeah and
Joel with Post Line and do and here's
the thing I used to go like every week
and Joe had a new 30 minutes
hahaha
a new 30. like none of the jokes were
old
before any commit and it's an open mic
before any comedian got up there he did
30 minutes I was like look at Joe host
lighting I don't know it wasn't my word
but we just I just heard it I was so
sliding yeah it's real what he does
yeah it's real yeah and this was you
know a patio of a coffee shop that I
hosted for years I use that as just that
was I was just that was your night I was
doing all sorts of weird stuff out there
yeah all sorts of weird stuff but that's
that's probably the spot that like got
you good at being comfortable with as
much weird stuff as possible for sure
for sure
yeah yeah and that was something um
and this is not a flex but that's
something Paul verzi said about my set
is he talked about like the silly goofy
side and like I need to I need to tap
into that more too I think I've spent so
much time trying to be cool on stage and
be like yeah I know how to say things
but and it's like I'm just a goofball
and I want you just reminded me that's
how I started was just being weird and
Goofy and silly I need to get back to
that weird and Goofy and you are not
cool
I hate to be the one
I know cool when I see it
yeah you gotta you gotta let that one go
you are yeah yeah consider it gone
a very like not curious personality like
I've never like I don't think we've ever
spent like five minutes where we didn't
laugh within those five minutes even if
we were talking about something serious
that's just not within like your
personality it's just a straight lace
and just be deadpan all right let's talk
about these metrics yeah yeah yeah and
if I do you just laugh at me yeah like
what are you doing what are you talking
about
yeah that's cool that's actually really
cool that Paul verzie saw that because I
think we see that because at the at the
at the uh
at the Country Club you were very silly
Goosey
I think that's why you went on long you
were yeah so you were just so in it you
were just having so much fun because
also like I also think it's also one of
those weird places that you didn't have
anyone introduce yourselves introduced
right so you introduced yourself which
was very silly to do as well so you
introduce yourself you like coming to
the stage Joe Byers it's like guess what
it's me guys I'm the one coming to the
stage so like I think just your whole
Persona made it silly Goosey and but the
audience is like that they're like oh
look at this
Joel Osteen looking
Joe buyers and Joel Osteen gotta get
that gotta get the Hat yeah yeah
you got to see the impression on the
live stream
lit watch it on the live stream
a member and a subscriber
the hot breath holy church
I love it not only the president I'm
also congregant
I closed out my dry bar with Joel Osteen
I'm so excited to see how they
respond to it you know whenever it comes
out yeah it'll
it'll come out one of these years right
on it'll be perfect I'll tell you what
that'll be perfect timing
perfect timing I do know that it's gone
[Laughter]
but what
what oh like that like that oh he
doesn't just interview people oh
oh
he bowed that about that all right
anyway I think I think we're going on
for too long
[Laughter]
so we know in the live stream for sure
um all right speed round all right speed
round
here we go Ty Erskine how do you manage
difficult times in life while pursuing
comedy
when do you write so let's talk about it
on stage
I always say
um
like life is supposed to happen comedy
is just a part of life in itself uh do
yourself a favor is that if comedy is
getting in the way take a break like
don't feel forced to keep doing comedy
if it feels like it's getting in the way
of like real life or if the timing of it
is getting in the way of stuff to do you
actually need to live to actually have
something to write about as well and I
think it's important just to
you know let you know as as they say let
let God take the wheel I mean just let
it go just like you don't have to do
comedy uh chill out go live your life go
take care of your business
um and then come back comedy's not going
anywhere stand up isn't going anywhere
just remember that no one's missing
exactly
[Music]
Kaboom uh next up
Amir what are your favorite joke writing
exercises
well I like free writing free writing is
always my go-to which is basically just
like free it's kind of like journaling
but it could be you're just writing
about your day or it's literally you
have a funny joke idea and you're just
writing freely not thinking not trying
to be funny you're just trying to fill
up a page as fast as possible and you're
just letting the thoughts flow out of
you you're completely free not trying to
do anything and I I get a lot of good
ideas from that
yeah
um yeah probably my favorite is I do
this kind of three column methodology
that I got from Jerry Corley he was the
first one I ever saw do it it's like a
late night exercise where basically uh
if you have a premise for something you
break it down into like three subjects
and then each column you basically write
everything you thought about that one
thing everything you thought about the
second thing everything you thought
about the third thing and you kind of
mix and match it almost like a Venn
diagram and then you see where the
connections are uh our buddy
Armory has this great website that
actually helps you put those things
together we can put it in the show notes
but it's like I I am stand up slash
write Aid yeah totally awesome thing
yeah ask about it in the Facebook group
I am not gonna hunt down that link to
put it in the show notes so no no but
yeah yeah yeah yeah
go in the Facebook group and uh ask
about it immedi runs the right tin after
dark which is a great exercise
for those of you listening what's your
favorite joke right here the right 10
Club there's a new word you can write a
new joke about and uh it's a great
writing exercise we do it in the
mornings and the evenings
um
Carol Freeman asked about tightening up
jokes that was the feedback she got from
the world series of Comedy
so how to tighten up jokes basically
uh uh you know I'd probably say probably
the best thing is to tighten up jokes
like
I always try to figure out what I need
for the joke to actually work versus
what is not needed so
um I it's it's just about like
practicing
different ways of how that joke is going
to be said insane huh I wonder if I
could take away two more words to see if
this works if I could take away one more
word and then if if it feels like I
can't take away any of those words then
I know it's like super tight but just
know like At first the first time you
write it you could probably take away
some words
yeah and you can look at it in terms of
time as well of like how much time is
between each laugh am I getting a laugh
at 20 seconds and then I'm not getting
another laugh until 45 seconds how can I
put those two laughs closer together or
how can I add a lap in between them
yeah you never want too long of a gap
between laughs
close the gap between laughs
uh Nathaniel Hood any advice for new
Comics trying to kill it at a three
minute comedy contest
[Music]
do your best jokes that have the most
laughs in it I think it's I know that
sounds super simple but don't try to do
like long bits really figure out which
jokes have the most laughs in it and do
that uh mostly because at three minutes
you're not really establishing a whole
bunch so the goal should be how many
jokes can I squeeze in here that I know
will get last for sure
and that's not even like and I love
doing three minute contests because it
really forces you to edit that's not
even doing tags like for a lot of your
jokes it's like what is the funniest
punch sign of this bit I'm doing that
one and then moving on and I would say
prepare for
time it out to end at 2 40 2 45 because
you're gonna feel rushed and you're
gonna feel like you need to cram
everything in and that's going to mess
up your timing and that's going to mess
up your laughs so I would also say to
rehearse it to end before three minutes
and not at three minutes
big facts we are killing it at this yeah
we're running it we're running it fam
Daniel podalak
has someone getting into comedy how much
time should I spend riding before I try
stand up
no time just try it
yeah yeah I agree just go yeah yeah and
what will help you get on stage because
I know a lot of people listen to this
who are thinking about getting on stage
and I haven't taken the leap putting a
date on the calendar will hold you
accountable
to actually get on stage it'll have you
something you can start to work towards
it can be in a week it can be in a month
but just get a date on the calendar and
that'll hold you accountable to actually
prepare as much as possible for it yeah
and don't wait till the end of the
fantasy football league uh to actually
do the stand up just go up and do it and
try it out
yeah
go for it you got this Daniel
uh because you can try it again and
again and again and then you never know
until you get on stage and then you're
12 years in and you're doing a country
club you know what I'm saying like
which people listening we are available
for booking people listening to this you
can book us to perform at your country
club you're someone you knows Country
Club a corporate event A holiday event a
birthday party listen where you want
entertainment oh this magic thing called
a budget like if you've heard of a thing
called a budget yeah they've got those
uh holla yes at the boys you know what I
mean but it doesn't hurt to ask us you
know and then we can talk about the
budget but we are married
and we do have a quota to fill so do
just just have empathy for if we're like
but how about this much
just know we have to stop taking table
cuts
for payments or or
exposure yes
exactamundo
but it never hurts to reach out and ask
because you never know we may be in a
certain area and we may just want to do
the show anyway and it's not just part
of like a one we may not make a road
trip to do it but we may already be in
the area just reach out let's let's talk
we love we love to work together
um
Amir asked how do you perform clean
material when you're naturally drawn to
the mischievous stuff that my rile
people up
um
that's a good question I I I would say
it's just easier if you try to write
clean
and then dirty it up later on then to
write dirty and then try to clean it up
so I think this is just more of a
writing exercise of trying to write as
clean as possible it's not that your
material
material isn't necessarily dirty or
clean it's just what people are going to
resonate with because from a material
perspective it just has to be funny
but I think people get into the habit of
trying to figure out
like don't do comedy that's like shock
value comedy like try to move away from
shop value and try to do like just funny
I don't know and there's also just
different ways you can say the same
thing so if you have a dirty joke ask
yourself well what is this joke about
what is the premise what am I trying to
say and then what's a cleaner way I can
say this what are words that could be
replaced with cleaner words and there's
usually always a way you could kind of
you can clean up always
oh yes yeah yeah yeah but it's all it's
not it's allow yourself to go to those
dirty places but just don't just don't
let the dirty part be where you end like
don't stop writing because you found the
dirty joke keep writing until you can
start to buff it up and uh make it clean
yeah uh
um um
Alvaro how do you balance going to
Mike's first writing I go to a lot of
mics but I feel
I'm not writing new material any ideas
hmm
I would say kind of like what you
mentioned around just fine holding some
accountability for yourself if anything
just challenge yourself on a regular
basis write one new joke and perform
that one joke at every like every Open
Mic gets one new joke that you've tried
and then you can work out the rest of
your material but just kind of challenge
yourself that you're just gonna try
something new or like just try a
one-liner just to get in the habit of
trying different stuff
um on a occasional basis but yeah I mean
I would just say you you gotta challenge
yourself and hold yourself accountable
to write new material
yeah and gosh I mean honestly
if it I mean
stay the stage I feel like is
the more long-term important thing
because that's where you're going to
develop just your presence and your
confidence
but
I mean even yeah it's like you don't
have to try a completely new set every
time it could be literally one new tag
to a joke it could literally be just one
build your set just one new line at a
time and don't put so much pressure do
you have to write all this new stuff but
just maybe one new line
every time I perform or you want to say
something you already have in a
different way or you want to deliver it
into a funny voice so there's ways you
can work
material you have existing there's ways
you can keep making that better instead
of just always thinking I gotta write
new new new it's like well what do you
have and how can you make what you have
better
oh yeah
first we need a fire we need a we need a
bar sound effect call me Joe bars
um
but I think we may make we may be at the
last one here I think two more is um
this freaking freaking crushing these
questions huh guy Hannah said do you
believe in the nine joke formats of
writing
I'm not sure what is that Jerry corley's
is that what he's talking about
um I believe in whatever helps you write
jokes I mean because there's so many
different writing resources out there
and some work better for others some
resonate more than others so just
learn and do research but don't just
research a lot of stuff actually put
these things into practice and you'll
figure out what works for you
yeah I don't know the nine joke format
so I am unable to answer that question I
think it's true it's a Jerry Corley
thing oh yeah it definitely works but
yeah just whatever helps like I have the
system that literally is a combination
of Jerry Corley
um from the comedy Bible Greg Dean and
stuff that I took from like my marketing
experience that's how I like write a
joke at a structure so whatever works
for you is what works for you yep agreed
agreed
um
and I think we had someone from Peru
hi I'm from Peru can you give advice to
produce a comedy event
oh man we've we've gone deep on this and
past episodes
um this this cliff notes for me would be
pick a venue that's gonna work with you
to help make this a success hopefully
it's a venue that's already doing other
other live events that a comedy show
would just be a natural fit so I started
doing music or karaoke or trivia
make it a place that comedy would be a
natural fit and a place that the
location the venue is actually going to
help you make this a success
yeah uh I'd add to that when you get the
venue make sure like that there's no
distractions like make sure the TVs are
off make sure there's not like something
else going on
um and kind of make try to make the show
an experience so like uh what Ava
mentioned like greeting every single
person that comes into the show uh
saying goodbye to every single person
after the show is done like those kind
of little things really make a
difference so make the comedy an
experience
kaboom
boom uh and then we got a new comic here
Cyrus Miller I've been doing comedy in a
smaller scene about a year and a half a
lot of people in my scene are moving to
bigger markets soon when would it be
appropriate to move to a bigger scene
the old age question of when should I
move to a bigger scene
I've heard it described as like high
school and college to where you do in
your scene for four years and then you
graduate into a bigger scene I've also
heard it that
once you're comfortable once you're
comfortable in your scene you're able to
get up wherever you want to and people
are kind of looking up to as kind of
this big fish in a small pond that's
when you'll want to take the leap as
well
that's a good one I think if you're if
if you can easily get up anywhere
and you want to move to a bigger scene
that's probably a good time like
if it's not a if it's easy for you to be
like oh can I get a spot
and there is no like pushback on you
getting that spot you're probably
crushing it in that spot and you might
want to try to find a scene that
challenges you
and a way to start getting out of that
scene not necessarily maybe moving but
you start by going on some road trips
doing different shows around different
scenes and really dipping your toe in
other locations to see where you would
potentially want to move so it can the
move can be that gradual as well
if you start to just get on the road a
little bit more once you're comfortable
in your scene and start growing
gradually from there
yeah but it's personal preference I've
had friends from Atlanta who jumped and
moved to New York and slept on the floor
with four people and ended up on The
Tonight Show so yeah it's kind of where
you're comfortable with
living your lifestyle
as a comedian what you're I stayed in
Atlanta
I didn't move to like a bigger scene or
other I just developed here and started
getting more and more road work I'm not
really on that open mic hustle every
single night anymore like I'm literally
more on the road and doing more
headlining sets and not really doing
these five minute open mics anymore one
reason is because like I can kind of do
that like I could go to an open mic and
just get up and it's just uh I don't
know it's it feel it does feel like all
right I'm kind of I don't wanna
I will and I can if I need to but it
just feels like I'll just I'd rather
save that for the road and work on other
things
I also think it's important to know that
like
if you are doing that well and you're
showcasing then you're just doing your
new material in your showcase sets or in
your headlining sets like you're
actually trying new material out in
spots that you know okay this might not
work but I've already
am crushing it let's just see if we can
add this new joke which is something
that all Headliners do they'll try a new
bit in the middle of something but
that's just because the audience is on
on board with them so that's also
something to think about is maybe you're
not trying it out at the open mic but
when you're crushing it like that you
can just try that new stuff in your
showcasing sets
Lavo
[Applause]
we did it
wow another good one hot breath verse
look at look look at us
look at us winning we've done it again
every Tuesday fam we do this join us
every Tuesday on our YouTube channel
join our email list so you can get
alerted to when we do go live every
single week and get updated on other
fun happenings here in the hot breath of
Earth
boom bow
wow
[Music]
we'll see y'all next Tuesday Hopper at
the verse I'm sorry about Yoshi there
we love you
dab have a good day y'all
bye